artificial intelligence is taking over
the world we can see in AI art some
pretty cool AI portraits in chat Bots
and tons more now you might think
chatbots suck though right wrong there
are already AI tools like open ai's chat
GPT that can generate short essays do
research give directions solve math
problems write high level coding
sequences and generate cooking
instructions based on certain prompts
they can even write entire movie scripts
now I'm not saying that these scripts
are oscar-worthy screenplays or anything
but they could definitely get there
within the next few years before we dive
into this though I just want to say that
I'm not here to scare Monger or say that
AI is going to completely take over the
movie industry overnight or even take
away your job but it's definitely worth
considering how AI could potentially
change the way we live our lives and how
we make movies in the future so to see
just how far away we are from AI taking
over the world I decided to test it out
write a title and script for a movie
that's a cross between Shrek and Back to
the Future
title Shrek to the Future write an
alternate ending for Avengers end game
as the dust settled on the battlefield
they gathered around Thanos who lay
defeated at their feet Thor approached
the villain
Thanos for your crimes against the
Universe I sentence you to a fate worse
than death you'll be forced to watch all
of the Real Housewives franchises back
to back
what
okay all jokes aside that's pretty
impressive AI technology is advancing at
an alarming rate it's already being
utilized in the film industry for tasks
such as special effects and
post-production work as AI becomes more
sophisticated and widely adopted there
is a terrifying possibility that it
could take on more complex tasks and
decision making within the industry such
as writing scripts or directing movies
the Cutthroat and cost-sensitive nature
of the film industry could also Drive
the adoption of AI leading to an
uncertain future for human professionals
we should brace ourselves for the
possibility that AI could eventually
become a central player in the
production process of our beloved movies
the thought of this is really terrifying
don't believe me well that entire
paragraph was just written by AI so
we're basically already there okay so
chat GPT can write but what about the
actual production of movies could AI
eventually take over tasks like
directing editing and even acting it's
definitely possible we've already seen
AI being used to generate visual effects
and create entire music scores in a AI
can create lifelike human profiles that
read out scripts so I don't think we're
too far away from AI Bots being
developed that can rival young directors
or professional video editors so what
does all this mean for the future of the
movie industry it's hard to say for
certain but it's definitely worth
considering how AI could change the way
we make movies it could lead to more
efficient and cost-effective movie
production but it could also potentially
lead to the displacement of human
workers and the end of the movie
industry as we know it I think tools
like chat GPT are just that tools we
shouldn't rely on them to do our jobs
for us but use them to get the ball
rolling or to solve simpler problems
when my parents were in school they
faced the rise of the pocket calculator
that could do math for you then I think
of AI like a calculator but instead of
doing exponents and reciprocals it can
come up with video titles or find an
issue and some code my fear is that
Hollywood will get lazy and rely too
heavily on AI platforms like chat GPT
surrendering the human element of
filmmaking to a lifeless robot and I
really hope that doesn't happen don't
forget to like And subscribe bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]